hallo ihr lieben ich bin richtig
aufgeregt denn heute zeige ich euch ein
richtig leckeres rezept für einen
blechkuchen den habe ich mir erwehren
ramadan ausgedacht und habe ich ihn
ausprobiert und dachte nur so hammer so
lecker und zwar besteht ja aus einer
schicht muss teig dann haben wir so
richtig schön vanillepudding obendrauf
mit schmand total lecker und
anschließend das ganze ab mit schokolade
und haselnüssen also perfekt für meinen
glauben wirklich ein traum und ich zeige
euch jetzt zuallererst den teig und dann
geht es weiter
und der besteht aus gemahlenen nüssen
völlig egal ob haselnüsse oder mandel
nimmt außerdem eier zucker geschwulst
und etwas abgekühlte butter vanille
zucker backpulver und etwas salz für den
teig werden jetzt die eier mit dem
zucker der prise salz und dem
vanillezucker in der küchenmaschine oder
mit einem handrührgerät je nachdem was
sie da hat fünf minuten richtig schön
dick schaumig geschlagen
[Musik]
ich hab das ganze jetzt vier bis fünf
minuten lang gemixt und das volumen hat
sich schon fast verdreifacht ist also
richtig schön dickflüssig geworden mit
dem handmixer würde ich sagen macht das
am besten sieben bis acht minuten lang
dauert es ein bisschen länger
und als nächstes gebe ich jetzt die
geschmolzener und etwas abgekühlte
butter hin und verrührt das noch einmal
ganz kurz miteinander
[Musik]
jetzt fehlen nur noch die gemahlene
nüsse und das backpulver und damit sich
das ein bisschen besser ferment gebe ich
jetzt backpulver in die nüsse und dann
habe ich das mit dem teig schafe
vorsichtig unter
[Musik]
so als nächstes brauchte ein backblech
mein backofen habe schon vorgeheizt ganz
wichtig 180 grad ober unterhitze und das
habe ich jetzt mit backpapier ausgelegte
habt ihr jetzt noch mal ein bug ram drum
herum gelegt damit vereinfachen schönen
abschluss haben und nichts wegschneiden
müssen falls ihr das nicht habt bleibt
die menge gleich alles bleibt gleich da
müsste einfach nur die ränder dann
wegschneiden und von natur wie schlimm
müssen und jetzt wollen wir den teig
einmal ein wo wir stehen so denn los
boden ist fertig 15 minuten hat er
gedauert und werden die stäbchen probe
übersteht dann ist er fertig also schon
mal je nach oben kann das auch ein
bisschen minuten variieren denke mich
jetzt zur seite der durfte schon aus
köln und jetzt zeige ich euch die
zutaten für unsere decke kleben
dafür benötigen wir milchfett stufe ist
vollkommen egal außerdem schmandt
speisestärke zucker und vanille exakt
oder vanille zucker
jetzt kochen wir zuallererst einen
pudding auf dafür geben wir einen teil
der milch so ungefähr 300 milliliter
zusammen mit speisestärke zucker und
vanille exakt in eine separate schüssel
und verrühren das kindchen frei
[Musik]
der rest der milch wird jetzt in einem
ausreichend großen topf einmal erhitzt
so lange bis es anfängt hochzusteigen
und an der stelle auch immer wieder
rühren damit euch da auch nichts am
topfboden anbrennt
[Musik]
sobald ich mich dann hochsteigt geben
wir die stärke mischung reinlassen das
unter rühren noch einmal aufkochen bis
es ein dick
der pudding ist fast fertig da fehlt
jetzt nur noch der schmandt dann gehen
wir aber noch nicht sofort hinzu denn
erstmal muss der pudding ausdampfen zehn
minuten lang schaut er gerne auf die uhr
und dabei immer wieder umrühren damit
sich diese unschöne haut nicht bildet
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt zehn minuten lang die
pudding masse kräftig gerührt und es
wird auch mal ein bisschen schwerer
nachdem es abkühlt und jetzt könnt ihr
den schmand mit rein geben und dann auch
wieder kräftig rühren bis ich alles
miteinander verbunden hat jetzt ist
unsere lächelt ihm fertig und wir geben
sie auf den kuchen und verstreichen das
schön glatt die creme ist jetzt auch
noch lauwarm und das ist auch vollkommen
richtig
ihr könnt einfach auf den abgekühlten
boden geben und dann verstreichen
[Musik]
sobald die creme schicht schön glatt
verstrichen ist muss das ganze jetzt für
zwei stunden in den kühlschrank also
mindestens zwei stunden damit das schön
fest werden kann und dann zeige ich euch
die allerletzte schicht der blechkuchen
durfte jetzt auskühlen mindestens zwei
stunden jetzt ist er richtig schön fest
an der oberfläche und jetzt können wir
die leckere glasur mit den mandeln drauf
geben hierfür habe ich schon gehackte
man in einer fettfreien fahne an
gerüstet außerdem habe ich hier voll mit
kuvertüre gerne könnt ihr auch
zartbitter nehmen wenn ihr das lieber
mögt und hier habe ich in meinem topf
sahne aufgekocht die ist ganz heiß und
die gebe ich jetzt auch die gehackte
kuvertüre
das denke ich jetzt kurz ab fünf minuten
damit das richtig schön schmelzen kann
und anschließend wird das ungerührt die
fünf minuten sind um die quartiere
konnte jetzt schon mal gut an schmelz
und jetzt hören wir das ganze gut
umgehen dann wenn keine klümpchen mehr
vorhanden sind die mandeln rein und dann
geben wir das auf unseren blechkuchen
[Musik]
darin würde ich gern baden soll jetzt
einfach auf den kuchen geben der
blechkuchen muss jetzt nur noch fest
werden um das heißt die schokoladen
schicht muss fest am besten im
kühlschrank dauert 20 bis 30 minuten und
dann wird er endlich angeschnitten und
mit einer tasse kaffee verputzt und dann
ist der tag auch schon gerettet nach der
schulzeit ist unser nusskuchen endlich
fertig die oberfläche ist extra so ein
bisschen weich das heißt ihr können
richtig gut durchschneiden die
schokolade ist also nicht zu fett und
jetzt könnt ihr selber entscheiden wie
groß in die stücke schneidet
[Musik]
die nuss schnitten sind so lecker ihr
habt zum einen diesen richtig lockeren
nuss teig der an sich schon total super
schmeckt also ich persönlich mit ihnen
auch so essen dann haben wir diese
richtig leckere schicht aus schwand und
milch und auch allein das schon schmeckt
total gut und dann natürlich was nie
fehlen darf mein lieblings kuchen ist
schokolade und dann nochmal die nüsse
mit drin optimal macht euren liebsten
eine freunde erfreute wachs nach die
genauen mengenangaben stehen und mit der
infobox ansonsten freue ich mich wenn
ihr das video teilt leicht und wie
gesagt euren freunden erzählt vielleicht
machen die ja auch diese menge kuchen
für euch ihr könnt ja animieren genau
und ansonsten eigentlich bis zum
nächsten mal auf wie die skizzen tschüss
[Musik]
was es ernst